enfin kings voyage que je fais aussi
nombreuses à son retour au pays
ce voyageur est emmené dans une salle
pour confier ses bagages nous
l'appellerons pierre un nom d'emprunt
parce qu'il craint d'être à nouveau la
cible des douaniers un manet d'abord
moment d'ouvrir mes appareils
électroniques
lorsqu ils inspectent les appareils
numériques les douaniers doivent
obligatoirement les mettre en mode avion
de façon à ne voir que ce qui est
enregistré dans l'appareil
la manière dont les douaniers ont
fouillé les appareils numériques de
pierre inquiète le commissaire à la
protection de la vie privée du canada
lagence et ses douaniers ont dépassé la
limite de ce qui est acceptable pour
respecter des renseignements personnels
des citoyens canadiens qu'ils rentrent
au pays
l'équipe de daniel terriens enquêter sur
cinq autres quand toutes les plaintes
ont été jugées fondées
ce qu'ils ont fait n'était pas illégal
mais c'était contre un aux politiques et
contraint certainement à
compréhension moderne de la vie privée
quant au contenu des appareils
électroniques
l'enquète démontre que le mode avion
n'est pas activé systématiquement que
des agents ont consulté des publications
sur certains réseaux sociaux que des
dossiers ont été copiés qu'un compte
bancaire a même été inspectés lorsqu'il
a lu le rapport
pierre a été encore plus et digne et
j'ai trouvé ça le monde sait à uzein
c'est simple bon sens là dans le rapport
qu'il a déposée au parlement
le commissaire recommande que la
politique interne sur les fouilles
soient enchâssée dans la loi sur les
douanes
c'est certainement pas de marchandise
comme une autre un téléphone cellulaire
il est temps que la loi soit modernisée
de façon à reconnaître cette réalité là
au cours des deux dernières années les
appareils numériques de 26 mille
voyageurs ont été fouillés le ministre
de la sécurité publique bill blair est
d'accord pour examiner la proposition du
commissaire ici françois dallaire et au
canada montréal